Oh
this is an old game of mine from almost
13 years ago from the European Youth
Championship under 12 was my first Youth
Championship and I wasn't among the best
then but I still managed to to play an
interesting game so here y2 sacrificed a
night and thus I need not only my usual
water but also some special herbal tea
to find the solution in in an earlier
exercise I explained that the first
thing you should look at is it checks
and captures well here captures don't
make much sense for white but there are
a lot of checks and the other moose that
should be considered so good luck
you
the move I played was rook F to D 1 now
the Kings way of escaping by the D file
is taken away and it will succumb to a
series of checks on the next few moves
I have several threats the most obvious
one is rook to c1 and then there's only
one square for the King on before but
now I can give a check with a rook on d4
and the king is no escape he has to put
the night on c4 and then both route
captures leads to making one so he tried
to at least take away 1 1 square with
the Queen taking away the possibility of
fruity 4 but now I can checkmate with
another series of checks b4 king takes
b4 route b1 now if the King goes back
Queen to b5 is checkmate so the King
goes to c3 and now another two checks
route d3 king - C - the king is it's all
the way over on the other side of the
board and that's usually not a good sign
unless as I'm told you're playing shogi
in which case it's very good but we're
playing chess and then it's usually
usually leading to checkmate and here
Queen to d2 and all the squares are
taken away with checkmate